- The essence of entrepreneurship
is about making meaning.
This mission statement is going to be good
for the shareholders, for the
employees, for the customers.
If HR is there, it's going to be good
for the whales and the dolphins.
We're going to take care of everything.
You should not be afraid
of polarizing people.
I'm not saying you should go
and intentionally piss them off.
Using your rock star roommate
who happened to be with you
the weekend you got drunk
and decided to start
this pet food company.
It's not the crappy logo
that your sister-in-law
designed for free.
You need to tell a story.
Why did you start eBay?
Why did you start Google?
And, you know the Latin saying
of, I think, therefore I am?
For an entrepreneur, it is
I pitch, therefore I am.
Don't scale too fast.
I have never seen a company die
because it could not scale too fast.
For you to reach critical
mass with a product
it's not because the Wall Street Journal
or the New York Times
blessed your product.
It's because lonelyboy15
embraced your product.
At this point in my life,
you may have noticed, I
really don't give a (bleep)
what people think.
- He's a Silicon Valley
marketing executive.
He was one of the Apple employees
originally responsible for marketing
their Macintosh computer in 1984.
In 2015, he joined the
Wikimedia Board of Trustees.
He's Guy Kawasaki,
and here are his Top 10 Rules for Success.
(whooshing)
- The first thing I
figured out and learned,
sometimes the hard way,
about entrepreneurship is that the core,
the essence of entrepreneurship
is about making meaning.
Many, many people start
companies to make money.
The quick flip, the dot com phenomenon.
And I have noticed in both the
companies that I've started,
and funded, and been associated with,
that those companies that
are fundamentally founded
to change the world, to make
the world a better place,
to make meaning, are the
companies that make a difference.
They are the companies to succeed.
My naive and romantic belief
is that if you make meaning,
you'll probably make money.
But if you set out to make money,
you will probably not make
meaning and you won't make money.
So my first thought is,
you need to make meaning.
That should be the core of
why you start a company.
There are three ways to make meaning.
First is to increase the quality of life.
My background is a Macintosh
division of Apple Computer
and I can tell you with
total certainty that we were
not motivated by making money.
We were motivated by changing
the world to make people
more creative and more productive.
We were trying to increase
the quality of life
for the Macintosh user.
And that was a great motivation.
It kept us going through
many, many difficult periods.
We were waking up in the
morning thinking how we could
change people's lives.
A second way to make
meaning is to right a wrong.
You know, this fish is going
to die after jumping out
but to right a wrong means
that you find something
that's wrong in the world
or you notice something
and you want to fix that.
This might be particularly
applicable to not-for-profits
where, you know, there's
pollution, or there's crime,
or there's abuse and they just,
their very core is to end that wrong.
And the third way to make meaning
is to prevent the end of something good.
That you see something
beautiful, something wonderful
and you just can't stand the
fact that it's been eroded,
it's being changed, it's being ruined.
So I ask you, as you start your companies,
your not-for-profits, your
churches, your schools,
whatever you're starting,
please have one of
those three motivations,
one or more of those motivations.
If you don't have any
of those motivations,
I suggest that you
rethink what you're doing.
Because there are too
many MBAs in the world,
and I have an MBA, because
there are too many MBAs
and too many of you have
worked for Bain or McKinsey,
or Arthur D. Little, somehow
you think that you should
make a mission statement.
And the way you make a mission
statement is typically this.
You go on a two-day offsite
with the executive team.
The executive team, the
first day of this offsite,
you're outdoors, you're at the
Ritz-Carlton Half Moon Bay,
for example, because that's
why you go on these offsites.
So you go to the
Ritz-Carlton Half Moon Bay
and there's a facilitator
and the first day you create
these cross functional teams
and the facilitator says,
alright, one of you from
each team come to the front,
everybody else get behind
him or her, turn around,
shut your eyes, open up
your arms and fall backwards
into their arms because
we're going to build trust.
(audience laughing)
You're going to learn that your
teammates are there for you.
So turn around, shut your
eyes, spread your arms,
and fall backwards.
So after one day of this bullshit,
the second day you're all in a small room,
there's a bunch of white papers, you know,
those tablets of papers
and there's a facilitator
who knows nothing about your industry.
And that facilitator's going to help you
craft this mission statement.
And this mission statement
is going to be good
for the shareholders, for the
employees, for the customers,
if HR is there it's going
to be good for the whales
and the dolphins, we're going
to take care of everything.
(audience laughing)
And what happens is you get a
mission statement like this.
The mission of Wendy's is
to deliver superior quality
products and services for
our customers and communities
through leadership,
innovation, and partnerships.
(audience laughing loudly)
Now,
(audience applauding)
don't get me wrong, I love Wendy's.
I have four children.
By definition, I like Wendy's, okay?
But I have to tell you, in
all the times that I've eaten
at Wendy's it has never
occurred to me that I am
participating in something
involving leadership,
innovation, and partnerships.
(audience laughing)
I dare say that if you ask
Trixie or Biff working at Wendy's
what is the mission statement of Wendy's,
not one could repeat this.
I also dare say that not
even the founder of Wendy's,
Dave Thomas, could repeat this.
I know that's not true because he's dead.
(audience laughing)
This is a useless kind of statement.
It's too long, it's not
unique, it's not memorable.
As an entrepreneur, someday
when you have 15,000 employees,
you're trading on Nasdaq and
you spend two million dollars
to build your annual report,
fine, make a dumb ass
mission statement like this.
But right now, in the
entrepreneurial stage,
I submit to you, you
should create a mantra.
Three or four words.
A mantra.
Ironically, entrepreneurs
who should have this bias
toward action often can't get going.
They are victims of
engineering creeping elegance
where they always want
to add one more feature.
Or they're marketing people and they need
that external validation,
they want to prove that there's a market,
they have to read one
more consulting study,
or they're trying to get
a focus group to prove
that the product works.
They need one more focus
group, one more test suite,
one more something.
It's a bunch of crap.
So here's the three recommendations
about getting going.
The first is you've got to think different
as an entrepreneur.
Your goal should not be to
do something 10%, or 15%,
or 20% better, it should be to
do something 10 times better.
It should not be a
slightly better Apple II,
it should not be slightly better MS DOS,
it should be a completely
different operating system.
Think different.
Build the product or
service that you love.
I moderated a panel on Saturday
where a venture capitalist
from Sequoia was on the panel.
And he said that the best
source of entrepreneurial talent
for Sequoia, the best
places and companies to fund
are people under 30 years old
who are solving a personal problem.
Hence, Google, hence, Yahoo, hence Sysco.
That's the kind of sweet spot
for a venture capitalist.
Think different.
Don't just do the 15th
thing, think different.
The second point about getting
going is do not be afraid
of polarizing people.
You know, many people are
afraid to polarize people,
and my God, some people
might not like what we do.
And so they try to create
this product or service
that everybody likes.
That is impossible.
You should not be afraid
of polarizing people.
I'm not saying you should
go and intentionally
piss them off, but you
should not be afraid
of polarizing people.
The ideal situation is where
some people really love
your product and some
people hate your product,
but very few people feel
sort of disinterested
or neutral towards your product.
You know, something
like a Toyota Scion XB,
you either love that design
and you think it's very cool
or you think that's a
refrigerator on wheels.
(audience laughing loudly)
But there's nothing in middle,
there's nothing in the middle.
Same thing with the mini Cooper,
same thing with the Murano,
same thing with a Macintosh,
same thing with a Harley Davidson.
You either love the product
or hate the product,
but don't be afraid to polarize people.
And the third point is you
need to find a few soul mates.
I think there's a vast
myth about entrepreneurship
that it's Steve Jobs changing
the world single-handedly,
Bill Gates changing the
world single-handedly,
Richard Branson changing
the world single-handedly,
Anita Roddick changing
Mary Kay changing the
world single-handedly.
It's not true, it's not true.
You need soul mates, you
need, I think ideally,
three people in a founding team.
Because when one person
falls down you need the other
two people to pick you up.
And when one person is
cold you need other people
to hug you and keep you warm.
It's very hard to keep yourself warm,
it's very hard to hug yourself, alright?
So find a soul mate.
For Bill Gates there was Steve Ballmer,
for Steve Jobs there was Steve Wozniak.
Find a few soul mates
that balance you off,
that keep you warm, that'll pick you up.
Mistake number one that
entrepreneurs do is all the time,
and if you're going to pitch me,
you better avoid this mistake,
which is to take this
big number and multiply
by a mere one percent.
So this is how the pitch goes.
Pretend you go back in time 15 years ago
and you're pitching Pets.com.
So Pets.com was a dot com
start-up, it sold dog food online.
Okay, so this is the pitch.
There are 300 million
Americans, these Americans,
roughly one in four own
a dog, 75 million dogs.
Each dogs eats two can
of dog food per day,
150 million cans of dog food per day.
And this is not B2B,
this is B2C,
or more accurately, B2D,
(audience laughing loudly)
because dogs, dogs do
not take the weekend off.
Dogs eat everyday, right?
So total adjustable market
is one and half million
cans of dog food per day, or excuse me,
150 million cans of dog
food per day times 365.
Now, let's be conservative
because that's a favorite word
of entrepreneurs, let's be conservative.
Let's pretend that we can
get a mere one percent
of this market, you know, how
hard could that possibly be
to get a mere one percent
of 150 million cans of dog food per day?
So one percent of 150 million
cans of dog food per day,
you don't need to go to
Stanford to figure out that,
it's one and a half million
cans of dog food per day.
One and half million
cans of dog food per day,
let's say you conservatively
make a buck per can.
That's a million and a
half dollars per day.
One and half million dollars
a day of gross revenue
times 365 equals $500
million dollar business.
Conservatively speaking, worst case, okay?
(audience laughing)
Do you not hear this kind of pitch
every frickin' day of the year?
Right, right.
So, that's what people
do and you know what?
It's total (bleep), it's total (bleep)
because you cannot address
that kind of market.
This is saying, you know,
how hard could it be to get
one percent of the people
in China to drink my soda?
Well, that's not so easy to
get one percent of the people
in China to drink your soda.
So the solution for this
is that you calculate
from the bottom up.
Okay, so if you used the mistaken way,
you calculate one and
half million cans per day,
conservatively speaking.
Let's go from the bottom.
So from the bottom, using
your rockstar roommate
who happened to be with you
the weekend you got drunk
and decided to start
this pet food company,
(audience laughing)
and because, you know, you
have no technical skills
and he has one class in
programming, he's the CTO now, okay?
(audience laughing loudly)
You know, I can tell you,
you're familiar with this practice, right?
Right.
Okay, so CTO and CEO.
And so this is how you
do a bottom-up analysis.
You say, alright, so with
my rockstar, you know, PHP,
Ruby expert, roommate, he's
going to write this great,
or she's going to write
this great website and,
but let's just think, like, so website,
the selling pet food online,
eh, let's figure that we can
get 50,000 unique visitors a month,
let's be a little conservative, 50,000.
And of those 50,000 people,
let's say that using the same
conservative number, one percent
of the people buy dog food.
They actually buy dog food, right?
So one percent of 50,000 is 500, right?
Is that right?
Yeah.
So 500.
So 500 people buy.
These 500 people, they buy a case.
So it's 500 times 30,
so now we're at 15,000.
So, like, okay, so we have
15,000 cans of dog food per day.
Let's, you know, let's round up a little.
So maybe we get to 15,
maybe we get to 20,000.
But 15,000 or 20,000 is a long way
from one and a half million, right?
So, using the top down analysis,
you come up with a conservative
one and half million per day.
Using the more conservative,
you know, bottom-up analysis,
you come up with 15,000 per day.
Let me tell you something.
You are going to be much
closer to 15,000 per day
than one and a half million.
And that's how you prevent this mistake.
You have to be realistic.
You can't just go from this
big old number and try to
scrunch it down using
conservative estimates,
you need to start from the bottom.
Can you get 50,000 people
to visit your website a day?
Will one percent actually
buy the dog food?
That's a much more relevant way.
So that's how you avoid this mistake.
And the results will always be
closer to the bottom-up
analysis than the top down.
In all my years of working
with entrepreneurs,
I have never seen a company
meet their financial projection.
Never.
It never happens.
The fifth thing is to weave a MAT.
MAT stands for milestones,
assumptions, and tasks.
I happen to love ice hockey.
I happen to love ice hockey
and there are two of my friends
here from Ice Oasis where I
play ice hockey in Redwood City.
And one of the pleasures
of ice hockey is to be
the first person on the
ice after the Zamboni.
Because after the Zamboni
has shaved the ice,
the ice is just pure smooth
virgin ice, no cuts, no ruts.
It's a beautiful thing and
when you skate you can see
exactly where you skated.
It's a lovely feeling.
It's like being the first
person down the mountain
in skiing or snowboarding.
A new company is largely like that.
It's a pure sheet of
wonderful, smooth ice.
There's no pain in the ass
customers who are trying
to get a free upgrade,
there's no stupid employees
you made a mistake hiring,
there's not the crappy
commercial real estate
that you paid $15 bucks
a month for in the height
of the dot com phenomena,
there's not the crappy furniture
you bought at Office Depot one day,
it's pure, pure wonderful ice.
It's not the crappy logo
that your sister-in-law designed for free.
(audience laughing)
You're starting from scratch,
it's beautiful, beautiful.
The Zamboni just left the ice.
When you have that situation,
it's very difficult to prioritize.
This is about prioritization.
The first thing you need to do
is come up with a handful of milestones.
Milestones are things
like finishing the design,
shipping the software.
When you're starting a company,
you often think, my God,
we could either finish the design today
or go order stationary.
Seems like they're both
about the same importance.
It's not true.
A milestone is something that
you would call up your spouse
and say, honey, today we shipped.
That's very different than
calling up your spouse
and saying, honey, today
we ordered stationary.
(audience laughing)
That's not quite the same.
The next thing you do is you write down
the assumptions of your company.
How many sales calls can you make per day?
What's the customer ROI?
How much does it cost to
install our software or product?
These assumptions change
your business model.
Very few companies or start-ups
write them down and test them.
Write them down and test them.
And the third thing is then to do tasks.
Tasks are the things that
help you either accomplish
a milestone or test an assumption.
But the priority for an
entrepreneur is milestones,
assumptions, and tasks, M-A-T.
You need to tell a story.
Most people, particularly in technology,
are horrible at telling stories.
You need to tell a story.
Why did you start eBay?
Why did you start Google?
Why did you start Apple?
You can even make up the
story after the fact, okay?
(audience laughing)
One of the great legends of
Silicon Valley is that eBay
was because Pierre Omidyar's girlfriend
wanted to sell PEZ dispensers, okay?
The truth is that he
really wanted to create
a perfect market where demand
and supply cross each other.
The perfect market.
And to have a perfect market,
you need to eliminate geography.
The story of the PEZ
dispenser is after the fact.
Now, I'm not encouraging you to lie,
but I am telling you a
story is much more powerful
when you launch.
Why you two in a garage
knew there was a better way
to search or you wanted to
bring personal computers
to more people, or you wanted
a place where people could
upload video of people dropping
Mentos into diet Cokes,
you know,
(audience laughing)
whatever it is, tell a story.
The next thing is the art of pitching.
Pitching is usually used to raise money.
But pitching, more generically,
is about the process of seeking agreement.
You can seek agreement for money,
you can seek agreement to recruit,
you can see agreement for partnership,
and you can seek agreement for sales.
Pitching.
You know the Latin saying
of I think, therefore I am?
For an entrepreneur it is
I pitch, therefore I am.
An entrepreneur is always pitching.
There is what I call the 10/20/30 rule.
The 10 part of the 10/20/30
rule is that the optimal
number of slides for a
PowerPoint pitch is 10.
Maybe it's 15, but it's not
the 50 that you think it is.
If you can cover these
10 subjects very well,
then next step will be due diligence.
Many people think that if
you put 50 slides together
the audience will be
overcome with shock and awe
and all they can ask is how
do I wire you the money?
I have never ever seen
that happen, alright?
The purpose of a pitch is
to get to the next stage
of due diligence.
The purpose of a pitch
is not to try to close
the venture capital firm,
the partner, the customer,
in that meeting.
The second point is the 20.
I think you should be able to
use these 10 slides in 20 minutes.
You may have a 60 minute meeting
but I guarantee you it'll start late.
The partners from the
firm will come in late.
You're using a Windows laptop,
you can't make it work with the projector.
(audience laughing)
Something will go wrong.
And the third point is 30 point font.
The smallest font you should
use on a slide is 30 points.
This single recommendation
will prevent you
from getting in trouble with most slides.
Lots of people like to use
eight, 10, or 12 point font,
they like to write out
the entire paragraph
and then they read the paragraph.
People can read faster than you can talk
so if you put all of the
text that you want to say
up on the slide, they will
read it, if they can see it,
and they will be done
before you've explained it.
The ideal size font is 30.
If you think this is too dogmatic,
let me give you an algorithm.
The algorithm is find out
who the oldest person will be
in the meeting, take that
age and divide by two.
(audience chuckling)
Okay?
So unless you're
presenting to 16 year olds,
do not use the eight point font.
You scale too fast.
This is, the foundation of this mistake
is the previous slide.
So this is how scaling too fast works.
So, we have now calculated
that conservatively speaking
we're going to do one and a half million
cans of dog food per day.
Oh, my God.
We need to really put in
a service infrastructure.
We need to have multiple
warehouses because we need
the dog food shipping out.
A million and a half
cans of dog food per day,
you know, we should have a headquarter,
we should have a shipping
facility in northern California,
southern California, we need one in Texas,
we need one in Chicago,
we need one in Boston,
we need one in Miami,
we need one in Burlington, North Carolina.
We need one everywhere because, damn it,
we're going to have great service.
And so we need these multiple warehouses,
we need support 24 x 7
because people are going to be
buying dog food all over
time, all the places,
one and a half million cans a
day, conservatively speaking.
(audience chuckling)
Ahh!
And so what happens?
You make your burn come
out, half a million dollars.
And guess what?
Your rockstar CTO roommate
is late on the software.
And so you're burning
half a million dollars
because you have all this
infrastructure, you have people,
you have buildings, you
have all these systems
and all these things in place
and the software is late.
This goes on for a year, right?
And so during that year
your investors are now
getting a little antsy but
you say to your investors,
you know, we've invested so
much training these people
how to sell and support dog
food and these are rockstar
support people and our CTO says that
we're going to ship next month
so it would be really stupid
to fire these rockstar support people
because in 30 days we're
going to have to hire back
the same kind of people and
then we'll have to train them
because it's so hard to
sell dog food online,
we have so much invested in them,
so let's keep these people on.
And for the first three or
four board meetings your board,
because they're mostly
looking at their Blackberries,
are not going to even hear this
and they're going to sort of
nod to do anything, alright?
But by about the six,
seventh, eighth board meeting
when you're burning
half a million dollars,
your board is going to wake
up and they're going to say,
you know something, we're
starting to not believe you.
And so the key here is
don't scale too fast.
I have never seen a company die
because it could not scale too fast.
For once in my life, God
willing, I would like to have
a problem where a company
I'm affiliated with has
such demand it cannot
keep up with the demand.
God, please give me that problem
just once in my life, okay?
So the solution to this
problem is my philosophy that
you eat what you kill.
In other words, you
don't build the kitchen,
you don't build the chef,
you don't get the waiters,
you don't get the restaurant,
you don't get anything
until you actually kill something.
And then once you kill
something, once you get the sale,
then you build the infrastructure,
then you build the support.
Now, you're going to
say, well, Guy, you know,
if you do this and
you're actually on time,
then you might have a bad reputation.
You can't fulfill orders fast enough,
you can't do something
like that, but again,
I've never seen it happen.
So a very good discipline is, you know,
if you think that you're going to get
25 million page views a month,
so you need to have two sets of buildings,
and you need two sets of IT
and all of this customer
service, I'll tell you what,
when you approach 25 million,
let's just worry about it then, okay?
But until then, because
odds are, you will be late.
Odds are you will be late.
So, eat what you kill.
You need to plant many seeds.
This is completely contrary
to classic marketing.
Classic marketing is
your plant a few seeds
because you know exactly
who's going to embrace your product.
And you water and fertilize
just those seeds, you focus.
I think that it's completely wrong.
In the old days, you would
focus on the A-listers
and the top tier journalists,
i.e. Wall Street Journal,
New York Times, Business
Week, Fortune, Forbes.
What you did is you sucked
up to them because you hoped
that these great oracles
of wisdom and knowledge
would embrace your product
and tell the hoy-palloy
and the great unwashed masses
to embrace your product.
Okay, so you sucked up to them.
If you didn't have time
to suck up to them,
you hired a PR firm and
paid them $10,000 bucks
to suck up for you.
Then the PR firm would hire
an oriental art history
from Wellesley to do the
sucking up for you, okay?
This doesn't work anymore
because the world has been inverted.
The world has been inverted.
And now, for you to reach
critical mass with a product,
it's not because the Wall Street Journal
or the New York Times
blessed your product,
it's because lonelyboy15
embraced your product.
(audience chuckling)
And lonelyboy15 told his 20 friends
who told their 20 friends who
eventually told Tiffany517
and lonelygirl to also
embrace your product.
And what happens, and this is how Twitter,
and this is how Facebook happen,
it's not because the New York
Times saw Twitter or Facebook
on the first day they
launched and said, ah ha,
we have seen the future.
We know with total
certainty someday Facebook
will have more members
than every other country
except China and India.
(audience chuckling)
Show me a New York Times,
Business Week, Fortune,
Forbes article that predicted
the success of Twitter,
or Facebook, or Apple, or Yahoo.
Pick any of the success
stories, none of them.
So what you need to do
is plant many seeds.
Put your prototype out there.
Cover the Earth with it
because you do not know
who your lonelyboy15 will be.
This is some loser of a
person who has no life
who's a database administrator
in the bowels of HP, right?
And this person may be the person
that makes your product a a success.
You cannot reach those people
by focusing and using PR firms
who have hired oriental art
history majors from Wellesley.
You need to plant many seeds.
I have much, I have about
1000 times more communication
with Google than Apple.
- Why do you think that is?
- You know.
- Was able just too into themselves?
If you're outside the Apple family
it's like your persona non grata?
- Well, yeah, it's kind of like LBJ saying
you're either in the tent pissing out,
or you're outside the tent pissing in.
So I guess I'm outside
the tent pissing in.
You know,
at this point in my life,
you may have noticed,
I really don't give a
(bleep) what people think.
(audience applauding)
So, now this is an enormously
liberating feeling and so,
you know, I don't really care.
I mean, you know, I don't think
Tim Cook even knows who I am
so, you know, what does
he care if I criticize
his connector strategy.
So,
I just like to tell it like it is.
I'm 58 years old, you know,
I'm 2/3 dead already so,
you know.
- What do you have to lose?
- Yeah, like, I'm not going to waste time.
You could also see me on social media.
When people attack me
and when people do things
I just block them.
I don't try to kiss up, screw them.
I block a lot of people.
(audience laughing loudly)
I just, you know, I have to
tell, the people that I block
the most are these just
total troll wussies.
I would like to use the P word there
but I'll use the W word.
And I just, there's like
a small number of people
on social media who have
such a feeling of entitlement
and I'll give you an example.
So Google is giving away
copies of What the Plus!, okay?
And so you can get it from
Google for free all day long
and so they put a little banner,
well, not banner, a little
GIF that said Click Here
to get What the Plus! for free
as a gift to all Google+ users.
So somebody says, how dare Google do this?
They said there would
be no ads on Google+.
And now I see this thing
where I can get a free copy
of What the Plus!
How dare Google do that.
Basically that guy's saying
my time is so important
and my screen space, my
white space is so important,
I have such a feeling of
entitlement, how dare Google,
which is hosting my
pictures, doing my email,
handling my social media,
giving me search results,
how dare Google put a little GIF there.
I cannot relate to that attitude.
To me, you know, there's
parts of Google+ I don't like,
there are parts of Facebook I don't like,
like why do they only send
my posts to 10% of the people
who volunteered to see my posts?
I can't wrap my mind around that.
It's the same guy who did
the Apple connector strategy.
(audience laughing)
- They hired him away.
- So, you know, like what,
you know, how do they?
What goes through their
brain thinking that?
And so these people with entitlement,
I can't stand that thought.
To me, no matter how much you
dislike Google+, or Pinterest,
or LinkedIn, or whatever,
you're not paying.
I mean, they're providing
a tremendous service to you
so the metaphor I like to use
is if somebody invites you
to their house for dinner,
you don't show up and say,
you're not serving what I like, right?
This is a dinner, you are
a guest in someone's house.
So shut up and eat or leave.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Dorian Taylor asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the Comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Guy's Top 10 rules
meant the most to you.
Leave it in the Comments,
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(whoosh)
- Partnership is a very,
very overused word.
In many circumstances,
the word partnership means
lack of sales, okay?
So since you don't have
any revenue you say,
but we have very promising partnerships.
In other words, it's total bull(bleep).
Most partnerships are total bull(bleep).
There's only one thing that
you care about, it's sales.
Remember, this is the most important thing
I could tell you tonight,
sales fixes everything.
(audience chuckling)
Okay?
No bullshit partnership,
nothing strategic,
you're either selling
or you're not selling.
Partnerships are bull(bleep).
If you want to apply a
more sophisticated test
to a partnership, when
you form a partnership,
did you boot Excel
and either lower costs or increase sales?
That's it.
Because if you form a partnership
and it doesn't force you
to recalculate your financials,
it's total bull(bleep).
Okay?
That's the test.
It is a spreadsheet test for partnerships.
Most partnerships you announce something,
two ego maniac CEOs
who don't know anything
about the business go
to a press conference,
you announce this great thing,
and then nothing happens.
The middles and the bottoms
of your organization
can't stand each other,
nothing happens, okay?
So use the spreadsheet test.
Don't form partnerships.
Instead, focus on sales.
Focus on sales.
I swear to you that most
entrepreneurs use the P word
in order to blow smoke because
they cannot use the S word, sales.
The ideal number of times
you should use the word
partnership in a presentation is one.
Like just say it once.
You have one partnership.
But if you start spitting
it out like it's the key
strategic strength for
your company, oh, my God,
you are in deep trouble, okay?
But generally speaking, unless
it changes your spreadsheet,
partnerships are bull(bleep).
Invoke reciprocation.
This is a a carpet that depicts the battle
between Italy and Ethiopia
because Italy invaded Ethiopia
in the 1930s.
When that invasion occurred
the people of Mexico
donated money and sent it
to the people of Ethiopia.
Something like 80 years later,
Mexico had this horrendous
series of earthquakes,
lots of dead people,
lots of injury, lots of suffering.
The people of Ethiopia, even
though they were in a famine,
collected money and sent money to Mexico
because they felt the necessary
obligation to reciprocate.
Fast forward a few years.
About right after the Civil
War, the people of Charleston,
South Carolina were using
bucket brigades to fight fires.
The people of New York,
including Union soldiers,
heard about this and
they donated money to buy
the City of Charleston a fire truck.
That first fire truck
was on a boat that sank.
So they had to raise money again
and send another truck to Charleston.
Excuse me, fire truck to Charleston.
Fast forward to right after 9/11.
The people of Charleston raised
over half a million dollars
to buy a fire truck for
the people of New York
because the people of Charleston
pledged that if New York
ever needed its help,
it would come through,
135 years later.
Reciprocation is a very powerful force
to make your enchantment endure.
It means that you have
to pay it forward though.
And I will give you
a couple of power tips
about reciprocation.
When you pay it forward, when
you do something for somebody,
if they have any social
skills they will thank you.
Right?
They will express gratitude.
When that occurs, the
optimal thing for you to say
is not you are welcome.
This is a lesson from Robert Cialdini.
The optimal thing for you to
say when someone thanks you
for doing something is I know
you would do the same for me.
(audience laughing)
Because when you say that,
you are doing two things.
One is, you are saying to
the person, you have class.
I did something for
you, you're thanking me,
and I know you would do the same for me
because you are a classy guy,
you believe in reciprocation.
That's one thing you're saying.
The second thing you're saying is,
let me tell you something, you owe me.
(audience laughing loudly)
I'm telling you right now, you owe me.
Let's just make it clear.
You frickin' owe me.
(audience laughing)
Another power tip.
You might think that when
someone owes you something,
you should hesitate on
letting them pay you back.
You know, I know you
would do the same for me,
but you don't really have to.
It's okay, it's okay.
God bless you, go on with your life.
The better thing for you to do
is enable him to pay me back.
Because you don't want him
carrying around this guilt
and hesitation his whole life, right?
So what you want to do
is relieve the guilt.
Okay, you can shine my shoes, you know.
You can defragment my hard disk.
You can delete the spam
from my, whatever you want,
you can make my Windows 7
laptop print, whatever, right?
(audience laughing)
So by doing that,
by doing that you alleviate the guilt
that he's carrying upon shoulders.
What you're doing is you
are clearing the deck.
You're clearing the desk.
Now we're equal.
I can do more favors for you.
You can even do favors for me.
You're relieving the pressure.
So let people pay you back.
It's good for them, it's good for you.
The next recommendation is
that you hire infected people.
I think that
an infected founding team
is probably more important
than a founding team that on
paper has a good background
and work experience or education.
You know, the people who
love the product or service,
that's more important than their degrees.
It's more important than
their work experience.
Focus on the people who
love the product or service.
This means fundamentally you
ignore what's irrelevant.
And in many cases,
education and work
experience is irrelevant.
This is completely contrary to
what most VCs will tell you.
If you have VCs further
on into this course
and if you ask him, well,
what are you looking for,
they're going to tell you, and
I'll tell you that right now,
you can skip that lecture.
They're going to say we want proven teams
with proven technology
and proven traction.
In other words, we want
people who have founded Sysco,
won a Nobel prize,
and they're doing $50
million dollars in revenue.
That's an early stage deal
for a VC today, alright?
By contrast, Garage is
in a different business.
We want unproven teams, unproven traction,
and unproven technology.
It's a completely different world.
The irrelevant thing is that,
you know, think about what an entrepreneur
has to go through.
So let's take what might
seem very attractive
to many venture capitalists,
let's say that on your
founding team is someone
who was a Senior Vice
President at Microsoft.
Most VCs would salivate at the thought.
This is a proven executive.
This executive has been
with Microsoft for 10 years,
has helped Microsoft grow, etc., etc.
But if you peel the layers
of the onion one level lower
you would see that that executive,
during his or her career to Microsoft,
had on average a war chest
of $50 billion dollars in Microsoft.
During that time frame they
had a market share percentage
of roughly 95%.
During that person's tenure at Microsoft,
that person's greatest fear
was the Antitrust Division
of the US Department of Justice.
Now you're going to take that
proven executive from Microsoft
and stick them in a garage with $500,000,
zero brand awareness, zero market share.
I would make the case
that that might not be
the ideal hire for you, okay?
Now you may be wondering why in the world
are there diamond rings in this picture?
It is because I am living
proof of this theory.
I graduated from Stanford in
a psych degree, as I told you,
I attended UC Davis Law
School, and when you say
you attended a school it
means you didn't finish.
(audience laughing)
I attended two weeks so
I really didn't, in fact,
I never got started actually.
And after that, I went
into the jewelry business.
I enrolled the following year
in an MBA program at UCLA
and while I was there I started working
in the jewelry business.
My first job was literally
counting diamonds.
So on paper, if you were
Apple Computer's, you know,
recruiter, you said, alright,
so we need someone to go out
and to convince the most
technical audience we have,
software developers,
why they should write Macintosh software.
I don't think the spec
would say, psych degree,
law school dropout, marketing MBA,
currently counting
diamonds in Los Angeles.
(audience chuckling)
That might not be the sweet spot, okay?
But what enabled me to be
successful with Macintosh
is I love Macintosh.
The scales were removed from my eyes
the first time I saw it.
You know, the clouds parted,
the angels started playing their trumpets,
it was a religious experience for me.
That's why I succeeded
because it ain't because
of my psych degree and it's not because
I attended law school for two weeks
and it's not because I
have a marketing degree
from UCLA, alright?
Ignore the irrelevant.
What is relevant is they love the product.
Second point.
You should hire better than yourself.
Very difficult for most founders,
particularly engineering types who believe
that because of their superior chip speed
that they should be the best salesperson,
the best finance person,
the best marketing person,
and the best engineering person.
You need to hire people better than you.
A players, by definition, hire A players.
B players hire C players.
And C players hire D players.
So pretty soon you'll be
surrounded by Z players, okay?
That's what's called the bozo explosion.
(audience laughing)
And what follows the bozo
explosion is the layoff, okay?
So avoid the bozo explosion.
The third thing is to apply
the Stanford Shopping Center test.
The way this works is suppose you were at
Stanford Shopping Center.
You see someone who's being
recruited by your company,
who's interviewing at your company.
But this is between you and
the person when you first
see him or her is from me
to the back of the room.
That person up there has not yet seen me
but I have seen them, or him, or her.
So at this point I have sort of choices.
I can rush over there
and say, hi, how are you?
I know you're interviewing,
can I tell you more about the company?
I really think you
should join our company.
We're just going to kick some
ass, we're going to make mean,
and we're going to change the
world with our technology.
Or, you can say Stanford
Shopping Center isn't that big,
maybe I'll bump into him.
If I do, I'll say hello, if
I don't, I won't say hello.
The third reaction is I'm
going to get in my car
and go to Vallco Shopping Center, okay?
If your reaction to the
job candidate is not
I'm going to run over there
and say hello to the person,
don't hire the person
because when you're creating
a start-up, it is a family.
It is a dysfunctional family,
honestly, but it is a family.
If you don't feel the
compulsion to run over there
and say hello, it's probably
not the right person.